he is the worldwide symbol of rebellion
and revolutionary struggle his
silhouette is familiar to billions
representing the epitome of cool
anti-establishment ISM yet few people
know the real story behind the legends
of Che Guevara and in this week's
biographic we discover the man behind
the myth
to reveal an individual whose passion
for social justice saw no bounds
[Music]
Ernesto Guevara de la Serna was born on
June the 14th 1928 in the town of
Rosario Argentina
his family was Arastoo critique with his
father Ernesto Guevara Lynch operating
construction and shipbuilding businesses
born prematurely the infant Guevara who
soon acquired the nickname che struggles
with asthma as well as pneumonia his
mother was the dominant figure in his
life teaching him to read and write and
impressing her belief in social justice
upon him J was the oldest of five
children the family were exposed to a
wide range of political and
philosophical thought with his father
being friendly with many veterans of the
Spanish Civil War the boy develops a
strong interest in sport excelling as
athletics swimming and rugby he was
known for his aggressive style of play
and the mental drive to push his body to
the limit che also develops a passion
for intellectual pursuits by the age of
ten he had become a very good chess
player and a voracious reader the
Guevara home was overflowing with books
on a wide range of subjects exposing him
to the ideas of men like Karl Marx
Sigmund Freud and Friedrich Engels che
also showed a great love for poetry in
his early teens chase interest in the
philosophies of great fingers of the
past that didn't to keep a personal
journal in which he would summarize
their main ideas as he formulated his
own outlook on life at school che he was
confident and determined a schoolmate
remembered him as incredibly sure of
himself and totally independent in his
opinions very dynamic Restless and
unconventional he acted more maturely
than many of his peers and associates
while still in high school he surrounded
himself with university students proving
to be their intellectual equal and
showing a political insight that often
even surpassed theirs on one occasion
his university pals urged him to join
them in a political rally he replied go
out in the streets so the police can hit
us with their clubs nothing doing
I'll go and demonstrate only if you give
me a gun in later life Guevara made
their comments that was certainly the
case for himself an ANA 15 already knows
what he wants to die for India's no
afraid of giving his life if he has
found an ideal which makes the sacrifice
easy at age 15 Guevara is ideal was
still in a raw state consisting of
little more than a passion for equality
for all and a rejection of materialism
still at this age he was more interested
in sport than politics he impressed
everyone with his fierce self-discipline
his asthma made it a challenge for him
to stay on the rugby fields but he saw
his condition as a barrier that could be
overcome with sheer force of will Shay's
self-discipline translated to his
academic life as well after graduating
from high school he completed a six year
university medical degree in just three
years
his aunt later recalled we would listen
to him gasping studying as he lay on the
floor to ease his breathing but he never
complains
for him there was a challenge
[Music]
J began his university studies at the
University of Buenos Aires in 1948 at
the age of 20 he refused to involve
himself with the political movement
against the Perron government staying
focused on his studies he found his
respite from academia on the back of his
500cc Norton motorcycle which he
nicknamed lap Ponderosa meaning the
mighty one yet Shay's first major
excursion was actually on the back of
the bicycle though one that he had
fitted a small motor tube in 1950 he
embarked on a solo trek across northern
Argentina
that would seem peddling some 2,800
miles a year later he paired up with a
university friend Alberto Granado for a
massive motorcycle track across the
South American continent
the two men traveled from one location
to another finding work as laborers as
they went at some Pablo they volunteered
to work in a leper colony it was here
that Guevara recalled seeing the most
impressive example of solidarity and
loyalty and this was among men who had
nothing materially he was also deeply
affected by the intense poverty that he
saw in every corner of the continent in
his mines this was an indictment of the
failing capitalist system throughout the
5,000 mile excursion Guevara kept a
journal in which he recorded his
experiences these were later published
as a book which was entitled the
motorcycle diaries in the 1990s the
motorcycle journey proved to be a great
turning points in Guevara 's life in
1960 he wrote the following because of
the conditions in which I traveled I
came into close contact with poverty and
hunger and disease I discovered that I
was unable to cure sick children through
lack of means and I saw the degradation
of undernourishment and constant
repression in this way I began to
realize that there was another thing
that was as important as being a famous
researcher or making a great
contribution to medical science and that
was to help people his experiences over
the course of his travels also it proven
to Guevara that he could exist on very
little he had the ability to push
himself forward despite food water sleep
or anything materially these qualities
were to make him an extremely effective
guerrilla fighter Guevara had taken a
year sabbatical from his university
degree to embark
upon his epic journey returning he threw
himself into his studies graduating in
1953 to officially become a doctor two
months later however he abandoned this
career and stepped into the political
arena
with another friends Carlos Ferrer
cavora headed for Bolivia the country
had just come under his first reformed
government the big issue was the
nationalization of the country's 10
lines a revolution was forming but she
refused to be drawn in stating that the
revolutionaries were not concerned with
addressing the causes of injustice but
were merely tinkering with the effects
rejecting the revolutionary movement in
Bolivia J and Carlos headed for Peru
here they found that they were unable to
open any kind of communication with the
downtrodden
Indians who according to Ferrer stared
at us lips as tight and forbidding as a
vice that refused to reply to our
questions still the Peruvian border
guards were sure that the two foreign
upstarts were forming some sort of
agrarian revolution from Peru they
traveled to Guatemala here a revolution
had just taken place J had not yet fully
developed a Marxist philosophy but he
felt a personal responsibility to help
the downtrodden his challenge was to
find a workable way in order to do this
the new revolutionary government in
Guatemala was led by acabo our bents who
had managed to pull together a group of
young army officers and intellectuals as
J arrived on the scene Arbenz was in the
process of redistributing lands that had
been nationalized from the American
United Fruit Company to peasant workers
the ever-present fear was that this
would provoke a counter-revolution that
would be backed by the Americans
che wanted to work as a doctor for the
Guatemalans in the jungles of Bataan
however he would be required to join the
Guatemalan Labor Party which was another
name for the local Communist Party che
refused to join claiming that he was a
revolutionary and that that designation
superseded any political affiliations
the arbenz government only lasted a year
due to the feared American intervention
becoming a reality
the CIA trained and financed a
revolutionary group who managed you
asked the sitting government courts in
the middle of it all was Che Guevara who
commented we are like the Spanish
Republic betrayed from within and
without but we did not fall with the
same dignity
finally he committed himself to
revolutionary action yet despite his
best efforts he could not rally the
Guatemalan people for a consolidated
defense
in the ends are Ben's weekly resigns she
had been marked for execution by the
incoming regime and was forced to flee
to the argentinian embassy where he was
holed up for almost two months his
experiences in Guatemala convinced je
that America was the great enemy of
worldwide freedom and that capitalism
was holding people in a state of
subjugation it was at this point that he
began to seriously study the works of
Marx and Lenin from Argentina je made
from Mexico where he began to develop
his skills as a revolutionary in 1955 he
met Fidel Castro who had been exiled
from Cuba after a failed coup Castro was
actively looking for revolutionaries to
join second attempts to overthrow the
regime a full hence EO Batista shaped
liked what he heard and he
enthusiastically signed up the Cuban
revolutionaries hadn't even left Mexican
asurs when they were intercepted by
Mexican intelligence services and thrown
in prison
it was J's first experience of
incarceration the screams of his fellow
inmates as they were being beaten and
immersed in water it had a powerful
impact on Castro though he was able to
exert influence through the Russian
embassy forgot all of the men released
from 1956 the small band of men were
undergoing guerrilla warfare training on
the Rancho San Miguel near Hal Co che
proved to be the outstanding student
among the group despite his ever-present
asthma the 82 revolutionaries they sat
out for Cuba on November the 25th 1956
on board a dilapidated yacht called
Granma none of the men on board were
sailors and they all got seasick with
most of the supplies being lost in a
storm
they finally landed in a swampy area
that led to a mountain range in the
southeast of Cuba for the next few weeks
they wandered around somewhat aimlessly
they found a guide but he betrayed them
to Batista's forces the rebels were
surrounded as they lounged around in the
jungle with their boots off and weapons
laid aside in the ensuing firestorm all
but 12 of Castro's men they were wiped
out Castro he was wounded in the neck
but he managed to escape with four of
his comrades in doing so he had to make
a fateful choice of this he later wrote
this was perhaps the first time
to choose between my education for
medicine and my duty as a revolutionary
soldier at my feet were a pack full of
medicines and a cartridge box together
they were too heavy to carry I chose the
cartridge box leaving behind the
medicine back Jai led his group to the
Sierra Maestra to meet up with any other
survivors he used what he thought was
the north start and guide him but it was
actually another star and the group got
hopelessly lost
they eventually arrived at the meeting
place by sheer luck for the next few
weeks the men had to rely on the
generosity of local peasants just to
survive it was a small victory and the
group struggled to enlarge their numbers
as they settled into life in the Sierra
Maestra mountains though few peasants
joined the rebellion they did build up a
network of sympathizers any who showed
any signs of allegiance to the
ptisserie government were put to death
often on the orders of Guevara it was
during this time that she developed the
cold ruthlessness that he felt was
necessary to the makeup of a
revolutionary over the next two years he
was to order the deaths of hundreds of
p'tee stew followers by May of 1957 the
guerrilla force had been rebuilt to
about 80 men and they had built up a
sizeable cache of weapons they overcame
another army barrack since before long
the entire Sierra Maestra region had
become a liberated zone where that
Easter's forces to go during this time
that rebel army had transformed itself
from something of a clueless mob to an
actual seasoned guerrilla force this was
almost entirely due to the training and
guidance of Che Guevara Castro had made
him a commandant second in rank only to
himself as well as training the men in
fighting tactics he also established a
field hospital the tailor's shop bakery
and a printing shop Guevara also set up
a radio station so that the rebels could
speak directly to the peasant population
as a result of his prominent work at the
core of the rebel army Guevara 's name
came to the attention of the authorities
being mentioned in the same breath as
the Castro brothers as an enemy of the
state within the group he also garnered
his own loyal following and in time he
would become a threat to Fidel himself
by the end of autumn 1958 the rebel
force had won a series of victories in
the south of Cuba this precipitated
chaise longue
march toward Savannah during which is
small but determined force traveled by
night and attacked the villages and
towns that they encountered along the
way during the day the ultimate
objective was to gain control of the
province of las viejas effectively
cutting cuba in half che proved himself
to be a brilliant tactician he perfected
the art of setting up rural bases
expanding them until a town fell and
then isolating cities and squeezing the
resistance out of it the final attack on
the provinces capital of Santa Clara
involved a suicide squad attack that
surahs men outnumbered ten to one the
victory that resulted was the most
decisive battle in the entire revolution
with the rebel victory at Santa Clara
and the rebels heading for the capital
for Henze Oh Batista knew the game was
up he abandoned the country and on the
1st of January 1959 headed for the
Dominican Republic with an alleged
fortune of 300 million dollars the next
day che entered ivana like a conquering
hero Fidel derived six days later to
proclaim that a new era had begun
[Music]
the men who now inherited the
governments of Cuba were predominantly
uneducated and ill-prepared for the task
the clear exception was Che Guevara
while he had no direct governmental
experience he was the university
graduates who was steeped in
philosophical thought further during the
time in the mountains he had proven his
ability to organize men surely
organizing a country wouldn't be much
more difficult as a result she became
the brains of the new government for the
next six years he remained in Cuba
implementing his own form of guerrilla
government his first focus was to shift
Cuba from an agrarian to an industrial
society in order to become independent
from foreign imperialists Cuba had to
become self-sufficient che spoke less
about the peasantry and more about the
urban worker in 1961 he was appointed
Minister of Industry and instituted a
program of converting agricultural
implements into raw materials so many
people buy such policies che he was
deserting the peasant class she never
appreciated the complexity and financial
resources that were needed to set up new
industries the factories that resulted
ended up producing goods that were of
low quality and high price by the end of
1964 Guevara had established himself as
an international expert on revolutionary
action during a three-month world tour
II visited China North Korea Algiers
Ghana Tanzania and a few other countries
espousing his anti-capitalist ideology
and claiming that the Cuban Revolution
was something spiritual that would can
send all boarders at the beginning of
1965 Guevara went to the Congo to lend
his support to the revolutionary
struggle there for seven months he led
an afro-cuban force of about a hundred
men however his movements were
constantly monitored by the Congo
National Army and the American CIA and
he was unable to make any traction
[Music]
after spending time in exile at the
Cuban embassy in dar elsalam Sheikh
quietly returned to Cuba then in October
1966 he slipped into Bolivia there he
believed that he could ferment an
uprising that would lead to the eventual
overthrow of imperialism throughout all
of Latin America during his time in
Bolivia Guevara caps a detailed daily
account of his experiences which had
been published as the Bolivian Diaries
the account reveals that the specter of
death was ever-present though it is
clear that he didn't go to Bolivia
wanting to get killed he was well aware
that the odds of emerging from the
struggle alive were slim at best J and
the Cubans who came with him not
welcomed with open arms by thei Bolivian
revolutionaries the Bolivian Indians
they distrusted the Cubans as foreign
white men as a result during the entire
11 months che was unable to recruit a
single Bolivian Indian to his cause che
divided his small rebel group into two
divisions he lacked the decisiveness and
aggression of the actions that he had
during the Cuban Revolution he was also
suffering physically at this point with
his asthmatic bouts becoming chronic
still his resolve to go on in never
wanes as long as he could breathe he
could fight each rebel division was
systematically hunted down by the
Bolivian forces on October the 7th 1967
an informants led Bolivian Special
Forces troops to Castro's camp in the
gyro ravine almost 2,000 soldiers
surrounded the camp and moved in for the
kill all but 10 men were killed
Guevara threw up his hands and he yelled
do not shoot I am Che Guevara and I am
worth more to you alive than dead
the wounded che was captured bound and
taken to a nearby schoolhouse attempts
to interrogate him failed as he refused
to speak one of the Bolivian soldiers
present recalled that che held his head
high looked very one straight in the eye
and asked only for something to smoke a
pipe was handed to che and he contently
puffed on it until a Bolivian officer
entered the room and grabbed it from his
mouth in response Guevara kicked out at
the officer on the morning of October
the 9th Guevara requested an audience
with the local schoolteacher
the young woman was summoned and she
listened respectfully as che brought our
attention to the dilapidated condition
of a schoolroom and
transitive to the lavish conditions
which government officials enjoyed he
told her that is what he was fighting
for the teacher
Julia Cortes later related that she
could not meet Shay's gaze because it
was unbearable piercing and so tranquil
soon the news came through the Bolivian
president Rene barrientos had ordered
the death of Che Guevara before the
execution the soldiers paraded him
outside the schoolroom and took photos
with him then he was taken back inside
where his executioner entered Guevara
stood as he spoke the last words to his
killer I know you've come to kill me
shoot coward you are only going to kill
a man the assassin soldier named Mario
Terran then opened fire hitting Che in
the arms and legs he was careful to
inflict wounds in such a way that the
story could be told that Shay was killed
during a firefight the revolutionary
icon was pronounced dead at 1:10 p.m. on
October the 9th 1968 the manner of its
death created a martyr while the
substance of his life created a legend
as strong today as it ever was
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos like this every Monday and every
Thursday and when you are hitting that
subscribe button do hit that bell as
well because that means you will get
notifications if you just subscribe you
might you might not who know so do click
that as well and as always thank you for
watching